và vì chúng ta nhìn những cái điểm biểu của anh những người nụng ta hỗ trợ
cho ta hãy đặt một có hoàn ngược lại
Điếp đứa chè này có tiêm lăng gì
Điếng cái gì mà đăng là cái mà họ tự hảo nhé
khi chúng ta gặp những người chè và gia đình của những người chè
thì chúng ta hãy nhìn vào các vấn đề hỏng
Bởi vấn đề hỏa là nhiều
Bô gia cứ bạo lực gia đình
mà các cố gắng dài quyết tòo là nơi đấy
Thật em ý, các cảm thấy mất tự tiên người bình thân mình
Thế thì quái trở lại kêu chuyện này sưa anh phào đờ
mại cố và chung
và là họ phía, nó mẹ hấp tốt, mẹ không loại
Rồi thông mấy cái
và lúc nằm cho vị cảm thấy rất tự hào và đàn tâm
và khi mà vị tự hào thì bạn thân đời thì vị muốn làm thế
muốn thế hiện thế
thì trong đây thì có một cái bản
từ là PK và sát điểm của bạn để cốm rất là phật tà
Mà để đến bố rù rầy cần thăm dạy cố lập mộ
thì không phá mạy cho thấy một con người hồn tật tháng
từ một đưa chè dù dẻ từ một đưa chè
mà thì có tự tiên người bạn thân kè hoặc lập đấy
nó là cái tình này để xú bạy ý hồn tài đồ
và ý hồn tài đồ tìm bà để trở thành hại
cũng phải các bạn khác
rồi bà đi đi thì mạy xam cả xí người bố này biểu gì ăn
cả trìm cuộc tế
rồi bà đi mắt đầu quay cho lại chung hào
bà đi học tìm này, bà đi đi dù hào và biểu
và bà đi chỉ bắt đầu mà một cái hạt đầu là bà đi đến
một rầy tật chỉ để học khi phục
nó là cái chất chút tắc
nó là cái khởi nguồn
từ gì đó
cái chất tipped cận của mình
nó đã mang đến những cái giá trịt lần hơn
được quên những lúc xếp theo về xếp tỏa vô vô kia sợp first step
mới nhất